autres les paiements
hypothécaires.
- C'est sûr que la première
journée...
- Juste une journée!
- Ça va être difficile.
- Les soeurs Valérie et
Sara-Audrée Piuze nt
à quitter leur triplex
dans Villeray, acheté ensemble
en 2019.
- On en a visité une quinzaine,
moi, je pense.
- Trois ans plus tard, Valérie
veut déménager en banlieue pour
plus grand pour sa famille;
sa soeur est contrainte elle
aussi de le faire, le faire, lee
de racheter sa part.
SARA-AUDRÉE PIUZE
- C'est dû aux taux, là,
je pense que si les taux avaient
s élevés, on aurait
peut-être pu se le permettre.
Mais là, les taux n'arrêtent pas
d'augmenter.
VALÉRIE PIUZE
- Ça - Ça - Ça cause beaucoup
d'incertitudes et beaucoup
de questionnements, beaucoup
de stress. On n'est pas capable,
en fait, de prévoir à quoi vont
ressembler nos paiements
d'hypothèque.
- Un mal nécessaire,
selon le gouverneur de la
Banque du Canada, Tiff Macklem.
TIFF MACerneur
de la Banque du Canada
- Il n'y a pas de manière
facile de restaurer
la stabilité des prix.
- La Banque du Canada augmente
sixième fois
depuis le début de l'année
son taux directeur.
Il atteint maintenant 3,75 %.
Mais va-t-elle trop vite?
MATTHIEU ARSENEAU, économiste
mon inquiétude un peu.
Ça s'est fait tellement
rapidement cette fois-ci.
On voit l'impact déjà.
On voit l'impact aussi sur
le marché de l'immobilier.
oronto, à Vancouver
et au Québec, les prix ont
reculé, les ventes aussi.
SYLVAIN GIRARD,
courtier immobilier agréé
- On sent qu'il y a moins
de frénésie. J'ai pas encorepase
d'écho de gens qui regrettent
- Mais forcément, c'est plus
difficile pour les acheteurs
de se qualifier pour accéder
à la propriété.
VÉRONIVÉRONIVÉRONIVÉRONIQUE CAR,
courtière hypothécaire
- Dans les dernières semaines,
je vous dirais deux, trois
semaines, on commence vraiment
à sentia certains
ménages, certaines familles qui
commencent à être essoufflées
par leurs versements.
- Sur une hypothèque de
400 000 variable,
la hausse de 50 points de base
de ce matin représente
une augmentation des mensualités
de 110 $. Depuis mars,
sente une hausse
cumulative de 710 $.
- C'est très anxiogène.
- Le stress des soeurs Piuze
est aussi monté d'un cran.
- C'est l'anxiété parce que,
oui, le taux directeur augmente,
mais il y a aussi tout ce
utour qui augmente.
Donc, ça fait en sorte que,
t'sais, l'épicerie, le gaz,
tout...- D'autres choix déchiras
en vue alors que d'autres
hausses sont aussi prévues
d'ici la fin de l'année.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau, Radn